come on Peter yes you're silly  it's heartening to see so many strange  noona faces here today I know my mom  would be very touched and probably a  little suspicious my mother was a very  secretive and private woman that's  grandma you know you were her favorite  at the rain even when he were a little  baby she would let me feed you because  she needed to feed you she was a very  difficult woman which maybe explains  means I recognize you from your mother  what sometimes I swear I can feel them  in the room she isn't gone  she had private rituals private friends  gonna take care of me you don't think  I'm gonna take care of you  but when you died she wasn't altogether  there at the end  I don't think this dad I don't like this  raise your voice  I just don't want to put any more stress  on my family  you